los brasileños quieren seguir viviendo
una fiesta aquí en Qatar 2022 si quieren
mantener la historia la historia que
viene repitiéndose desde
1990 Desde esa copa mundo la de Italia
la verde amarela siempre ha clasificado
a cuartos de final hoy se miden contra
Corea del Sur y con el aliciente de que
vuelven Neymar algo que se ha hecho
sentir entre los aficionados a quién
doha que confían con un nuevo Triunfo de
la canarinha
no chiste que sí es lo mejor noticia que
podríamos tener porque sin Neymar no
hubiéramos llegado hasta aquí entonces
estoy muy feliz por él y muy orgullosa
de mi país estamos muy ansiosos porque
confiamos en que Brasil va a empezar hoy
a disputar la copa del mundo la primera
fase fue una fase medio rara hasta en el
tercer partido jugamos con suplentes
pero hoy la copa comienza para Brasil
hoy ganamos bien para el partido de hoy
la expectativa es que se pueda conseguir
una victoria Brasil necesita demostrar
un buen fútbol como mostró en los
primeros dos partidos Y tenemos las
expectativas de un resultado de 2-0 va a
ser un partido difícil pero la selección
necesita mejorar para evolucionar voy a
arriesgar a que va a ser un Vocero y sé
que va a ser sufrido no sé qué piensa mi
hijo
tres a cero es mi apuesta y mientras los
brasileños se mostraban muy confiados
con volver a levantar la copa mundo 20
años después doha no es ajena al estado
de salud de orey pelea aquí en las
calles hemos visto muchos mensajes de
apoyo y mensajes de recuperación para el
rey Pelé uno de ellos muy simbólico el
que vimos en la grada durante el último
partido de la fase de grupos de la
canarina en esa derrota contra Camerún